a fiery speech from President Trump
brought an angry response from
demonstrators in Phoenix dozens of
protesters confronted police after last
night's speech some of them threw rocks
and water bottles at least four people
were arrested the president came to
Phoenix for a campaign style rally he
threatened a government shutdown over
his planned border wall and hinted that
he would pardon a former sheriff who is
facing jail time the president also
accused the media of misreporting his
response to the violence in Charles Bell
Virginia chip readers in Phoenix were at
one point the president misquoted
himself chip good morning good morning
I've covered a lot of President Trump's
rallies and I don't think I've ever seen
him this angry at one point he pointed
directly at the media platform that
dozens of cameras and reporters who were
there and called us bad people and sick
people
he still had anger left over though
after that he went after Democrats and
the two Republican senators from Arizona
I hit him with everything I got the
white supremacist the neo-nazi I got him
all in there let's say yeah KKK we have
KKK more than a week after the violence
in Charlottesville President Trump was
still chafing over criticism he was slow
to call out white nationalist so what
did they say right it should have been
sooner he's a racist
he claimed the media incorrectly
reported his word he wasn't specific
enough why was it any more specific
attempting to prove his point the
president spent nearly 25 minutes
reciting several passages from the
statements he made after the incident we
condemn in the strongest possible terms
this egregious display of hatred bigotry
and violence that's me speaking on
Saturday but the president left out
important parts including one critical
section of hatred bigotry and violence
on many sides on many sides mr. Trump
also directed his ire at his fellow
Republicans please mr. president don't
mention any names
so I won't without naming them the
president singled out Arizona senators
Jeff Flake and John McCain who cast the
deciding no vote that sunk the health
care bill we were just one vote away
from victory after seven years of
everybody proclaiming repeal and replace
one vote senator flake up for
re-election next year has criticized the
president publicly nobody wants me to
talk about your other senator who's weak
on borders weak on crime so I won't talk
about him nobody knows who the hell he
is
president Trump strongly suggested he
will pardon Arizona Sheriff Joe Arpaio
who faces six months in prison for
ignoring a judge's order to stop racial
profiling during traffic stops targeting
undocumented immigrants I'll make a
prediction I think he's gonna be just
fine okay the president even threatened
a government shutdown over funding for a
wall on the Mexican border he blamed
Democrats for blocking funding for that
wall and said one way or another we're
going to get that wall bill thank you
chip